partiamo risposta tra i due uno via o
dio allora let's go 12 devo fare il
poeta l'altro devo fare è una sorta di
record quindi devo provare a farne di
più possibili ed è veramente difficile
quindi non devo anche impegnarmi non
solo per far vincere il volto piuttosto
che che volevo fare
devo impegnare a prescindere perché una
sorta di challenge pure questa
quindi non favori non favorisce gerò
nessuna delle due
dopo stavo dicendo un italiano un po mio
buono l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho preso
che culo killer app ripari twin ce la
faccia ce la faccio a mano askoll
secondo al rai
e siamo a due ok il primo minuto non è
ancora passato non sono passati 40
secondi pavano su 12
no mi ha [ __ ] la spada non ci credo
gli ha fatto da scudo umano incredibile
è successa roba incredibile quanta
probabilità comunque siamo a tre
vado con lotto 2 comunque sono tutti
loro secondo me tutto è sempre la stessa
persona che ha fatto sì livelli perché
sono tutti molto simili però vabbè per
adesso è buono per adesso è buono per
adesso è buono ragazzi va a mano siamo a
5 fatti non quei quattro fatti le top
vai vai a doha myers casino ne mancano
unito perfetto sono un fenomeno oggi
sono un fenomeno non so cosa mi succede
14 vai cioè non è qui hanno fatto i 14
14 il nome del livello ma chi è che li
fa sono morto che faccio domande che non
servono inutili chissenefrega di chi lo
ha fatto o rai all right all right
e allora l'ultimo lo becchiamo non lo
becchiamo l'ho beccata lecco ce n'era un
altro ma no verranno messi 2 non vale
questo lo puntiamo sempre per uno
purtroppo perché un livello solo porca
vacca per non vale che me l'hai messo
insieme però porco il demonio un impegno
non ci credo non ci voglio credere perso
ma andate a cagare porco demoni oppure
perso devo rifarlo tutto solo perché ha
diviso i livello in due quindi non posso
neanche di farlo da da da zero solo
quello non dovrei fare tutte e due
porca vacca ma questo contiamo come due
ragazzi down vale quando avevo fatto
l'europa dei suoi troppo e siamo in
contatto davo coda come uno come due
come uno sicuro sono una persona troppo
ferrea sulle regole porca vacca
dopo un po di testa mia prossima volta e
bello che le faccio io le regole quindi
pensa se non lo facessi io ok e prendilo
cosa ti costa o perfetto e questo poi è
più facile
ok basta allora mia figlia e due ore che
mancano pochissimi minuti i ragazzi di
mancano 22 15 secondi le cose let's go
let's go no no perfetto ce lo dovete
fare un altro ecco vamonos dai dai dai
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai live score
per chi non ha un minuto ci guardano già
from my abbatterli con il volto secondo
me perché non fatti nonostante tutto
hanno fatti abbastanza tanti abbastanza
tanti italiani non è arrivata la
vittoria ma non c'era nessuno quindi lo
conto è che non c'era la vittoria se
bisogna essere e kaki e successo lo si è
caduto mi chiamano c'è la barriera non
ci credo
c'è veramente sono morto io con la mia
stessa squadra che mi è tornata indietro
perché cosa va la barriera c'è che
cacchio 6 avatar l'ultimo dominatore
dell'aria cosa sei ok ad opere solo
quello per vincere mica a saperlo rex
gaming di nuovo sempre lui era questo
che faceva sempre gli stessi livelli o
buono
manca un minuto manca un minuto siamo
sopra in banca un minuto perché i dvd in
due ma perché vuoi farmi perdere sto
gioco porca vacca te possino pia diarrea
spruzzo ma dai rega nome perché mi
dividono i viventi
ma dai già difficile già è difficile di
suo ok no
è questo qua e dai davanti ce l'hai ok
40 secondi forse potevo farne ancora due
se sono bravo bravissimo tipo io ero
fatto l'ho fatto l'ho trovato prima
donna hanno fatto i 10 secondi tra
l'altro incredibile perfetto perfetto
perfetto perfetto madonna che che che
voto il colpito dalla bottiglia no sì ce
la fai da te sa già che ci sono caduto
ti prego non ci credo non ci credo
l'ho fatto
3 2 a 1 shabbat a ciò basta questo l'ho
fatto l'ho fatto l'ho fatto
ok questo non l'ho fatto perché l'ho
saltato per sbaglio perché ho cliccato 2
fix e non due
quindi questo non lo puntiamo per questo
che sono stato a trovare quanto sono
quanto sono corretto oppure magari non
avevate neanche notato ma ho fatto così
dark e poi ho fatto invece che così ha
fatto tar quindi ho saltato questo che
non lo puntiamo perché non l'ho fatto
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 e 13 svolto
in cinque minuti è un gran punteggio nei
ragazzi è il momento di fare di padova 3
con i boltro e molto difficile fare
tredici boltro in 5 minuti e ragazzi
però ci proviamo
3 2 1 let's go minchia quello del tris
abbiamo già perso non riesco a fare
neanche questo con le altri sun è
impossibile
cioè tu devi battere il computer a tris
col volto cioè impossibile cioè i
giacimenti un sacco di tempo solo a far
questo aspetto stata la mia dietro
felice ok ci ho messo un sacco fare solo
questo porca vacca legge
cosa devo fare diecimila pre vincere ok
unlock no i civici dc dc dc 5.000
cacchio a dieci non ne faccio niente
bravissimo cimino vinto ha vinto vinto
vito
no abbiamo 100 mila non riesca a
prendere 50 mila ragazzi ci sto mettendo
due ore porca ho intuito ho fatto
qualche modo 100.000 lusso come le scott
jackson infatti due per adesso le due
minuti infatti due rho è impossibile
dai ceti cosa farai cosa faccin di
quanto tempo no ma come jeff hall
ma cosa aspetti ha vinto sinora dai fai
serio fra il serio ma non ho vinto
sono ancora vivo non lo posso vivave ma
purtroppo nova per questo lo conto come
uno dai jet phone non c'entra neanche
niente contro lo volto come uno tra i
non c'entra nulla ha messo un livello in
un altro livello che non c'entra niente
c'è proprio un'altra cosa neanche avesse
un altro poltro ha messo prova un altro
livello
ci sono un miliardo di palle a un
miliardo di palle una finirà lì che
cacchio bingo il bingo no al bigo e
possibile il king facciamo messo una
vita mi ricordo una vita ci ho messo una
vita impossibile ragazza non lo so
giocare neanche normale cosa volevo far
fare coi boltro non sono un vecchio se
ho 25 anni fammi fare 25 anni per tre e
poi ci vado a giocare bingo è che
cacchio a meno fame vivere cose da
giovani forse era meglio fare gli
impossible contro il mostro non fare
molto contro risultano perché sono
troppo più lenti poltrono impossibile 19
l'ho fatto come manca tutto il resto va
beh niente mi sa che ha vinto smart
trovi lì ho avuto fatto qual è la bingo
ho fatto uno due tre quattro e cinque
hanno fatti un po e 6 e 7 12 34 15 che
cacchio dico bingo era questa non quello
sotto figura del che non ho fatto
quindi non è anche uno due tre quattro
infatti quattro ho fatto 13 smooth trovo
e ho fatto quattro ball trovo che merd
boh non lo so io pensavo di andare molto
meglio che è molto non ci pensavo ci
fosse molta più competizione tra i due
invece purtroppo non sono impossibili da
fare vale proverò a fare un altro
episodio molto più avanti magari ne
faccio passare ancora un po e spero che
video vi sia piaciuto questo era svolto
tron contro boltro vincono ovviamente di
purtroppo ci vediamo non fosse bisogno
di di april fatemi sapere nei commenti
le altre sfide tipo questa era come
sempre ci rivediamo l'anno prossimo
video bella ragazzi
[Musica]
no